all right Texas passed a bill uh Abbott
the governor signed it went into law on
Friday uh basically they passed a law
that went into effect September 1st 2023
this past Friday that if you're
convicted of drunk driving
and you kill someone
who has minor children that's under the
18 under 18 years of age and younger
that you're now on the hook for child
support to pay until the child
emancipates which in Texas means turns
18 or graduates from high school
whichever is later so listen to this
hypothetical let's say you're driving
down the road and someone in their 1978
Chevrolet Vega runs a stop sign
unfortunately and you slam into them and
they die but your blood alcohol content
is over the legal limit so your per se
driving under the influence and they
have six kids by six different uh
fathers
the way the law is written is you're on
the hook
to support those six kids
until they all emancipate
you'll be devastated financially so just
another reason not to drive impaired
because so many times I you could get
into a automobile accident and you
didn't do anything wrong but you had
three beers in an hour and you weigh 175
pounds you're going to have over a 0.08
so you put you know you're per se over
the limit even if you're not impaired
okay but just that they do the blood
draw and you know your blow or you blow
in a desk top Intex uh taxolator 5000 uh
over 0.08 you're done uh if you kill
somebody you know it's going to be
vehicular homicide so the way the law is
written in Texas too the same law you uh
you know you have to start paying when
you get discharged from prison yeah
you'll ruin your life
so just another reason not to drive
impaired uh and I think other states are
going to start following this
Texas also recently passed laws
regarding inheritance and overdue child
support So if you're in arrearages and
you skip town you get a big inheritance
uh the law is written now that they're
going to go after that inheritance
before you can spend it or transfer it
uh child support or marriages in
Pennsylvania
uh sometimes can be reduced if it goes
in front of a judge and they find that
there's a reason to reduce them could be
a number is up until recently if you're
incarcerated in Pennsylvania and you
were paying child support uh the arrear
just kept accruing even though you were
incarcerated they stopped that because
if you're incarcerated for a couple
years how could you ever catch up with
that so uh in Texas now they don't allow
child support or religious to be reduced
so you're on the hook another reason to
protect yourself make sure that the
child is yours or don't get anybody
pregnant uh without being sure you want
to raise a child with them
um child support linkings in Texas uh
they're going to put a lien on your bank
accounts it used to be 10-year statute
of limitations now there's no statute of
limitations so if you owe child support
they'll find you eventually it could
take decades but it never goes away
another good reason not to father
children with someone who you don't plan
to co-parent with uh it's a world's
biggest mistake I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full-length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out